the use of force is going down how do we
explain that trend because force hurts
it hurts it destroys human values it
destroys knowledge hi I'm Zach why
smaller with reason TV we're here at
liberto Pia in San Diego and we're
talking with james payne an independent
scholar sometimes reason contributor and
author of six political illusions james
thanks very much for joining us today
like to be here what are the six
political illusions and what effects do
they have on the size and scope of god
these are impressions that people have
about government they start I think when
children are very on the first thing
they think about of government is that
it's like a super parent it has the
virtues of parent wisdom responsibility
money unlimited funds for whatever you
need so forth so I've divided that yes
into six specific illusions like the
first one is the philanthropic illusion
which is the idea that government has
money and I got to this from my daughter
when she was five and just learning what
was money I said Ellen should government
give money to poor people that don't
have any and she thought real hard about
this smoke was coming out kissed
government was it she hardly knew what
it was and then came up and said yes
because he has a thousand dollars so if
you see any problem anybody needs money
government has it of course the fallacy
of that is that government doesn't have
any money it's a system for taking
resources from one place shifting it
around are there some areas where the
government can act effectively
government can do like government can
produce a school and kids go to it so it
happens whether it is a cost-effective
solution you have to do all your math
which people are not doing never have on
the costs and benefits and particularly
the overhead costs of doing it this way
as opposed to voluntariness what about
the idea that there are some problems
that they're just so big that they do
need the government to you know an
economic depression
or famine can voluntary philanthropy or
something other than government step in
and you can you give an example of where
that it's well you know you'd want to
make if you're making that case you will
say government's power to use force to
take away trillions of dollars from us
will solve problem x which the rest of
us can't solve yeah or I'm going to
solve voluntarily maybe if a foreign
aggressors come in that might be
somewhat persuasive your work on the
declining incidence of violence has
inspired Steven Pinker's the better
angels of our nature how did you get
interested in this topic and why do we
see violence as a declining trend in
human society wonderful question you're
throwing a bone to a hungry dog as a
libertarian voluntarist and so forth we
are interested in the use of force so I
decided to write a history of force I
start with human sacrifice and take
every use of force I can find religious
persecution and slavery and so forth and
the evidence is simply overwhelming that
the use of force is going down how do we
explain that trend because force hurts
it hurts it destroys human values it
destroys knowledge so you see it as like
a natural outgrowth of getting smarting
together getting smarter it's a long
story but what happens is as the human
beings just go slightly past baboons and
so forth they're competing for territory
and they are in fact wiping out whatever
other tribe they can or they're being
wiped out well that process of warfare
selection will accentuate the warlike
virtues and values because the society
that says hey let's be peaceful we can
get along better by being peaceful
they're gone then their genes are gone
so it's kind of a miracle that you know
we got past that but we did or have are
doing it that's definitely a
ending on an upbeat note and thank you
very much James Payne for joining us to
it delight talking to you for reason TV
I'm Zach why smaller